first approach we should take is
everybody should realize if something's
on the internet that's free you're the
product yeah
okay so if you're the product we should
think of ourselves
as private property right so
if i'm the product and or private
property what goes
on your site if you're monetizing it i
get a piece of it
and i get to know what you're doing with
my information right it's not like this
form
that attorney has to read everyone just
clicks yes or no
let's set a foundation of what the
priorities of these forms should be so
they're clear spoken that people know
what they're getting i get
i get if you're monetizing i get a piece
of it if i want to get off your site
i get my data back if i want to move my
data i can move my data
i think that's a fairness that everybody
starts with
all right so let's let's shift from the
everyday machinations of politics and
talk to talk about the other big stuff
that i know has been on your mind it's
on my mind all the time let's talk about
the big tech stuff
we got some problems with big tech and i
know you're trying that's the thing that
can stop us from winning
yeah so so let's talk about that i mean
well first off i guess
how manipulated do you think we are
first like just
generally by big tech like just the way
that we're
able to talk to each other and
communicate more than we ever imagined
more than we even think about okay
you and i should have a discussion let's
discuss your book
don't burn this book and when this
interview's over i'm going to turn on my
phone
i bet you i get an advertisement for it
i'm okay with that
one i'm okay with but do we think siri
only listens to us when we
talk to them but what's what's even more
important
it's almost every aspect of our lives
right but it's gathering what
information we can know and what we can
think and what we can see but it's also
driving us to dislike people even if
they think differently than we do
and you know they'll tell you no no no
it's an algorithm
who writes the algorithm you know in
2018
right before the election if you googled
the california republican party
you know what they'd tell you our
ideology was nazism
how was that even in play google and
are you saying it doesn't say it anymore
i'd be i'm
yeah but what's happening here from the
aspect of
90 of everybody that searches goes on
google yeah
if you're on the second page 90 drop off
so they control whether you make it or
break it right but they also
if we are a young company moving up they
are so big
they take your technology they buy you
or they crush you right
so you don't have that free market
system you know when you sit back and
think
who should have been amazon sears and
roebuck
right they have the catalogs they sold
you from a house to the pair of jeans to
tools
they had the resource but amazon came in
a time where there was a free market
they started selling books they started
that
but now amazon's just not amazon amazon
hosts everybody
so if they want to take you off you now
can't be there
if apple doesn't want to put you into
the app
who finds you they control so much of
our live
think about if i grabbed your phone
you'd fight me
if you take your kid's phone away it's
the worst thing that could happen to
them
it's it's almost a drug to us now but it
controls so much what we can see what we
can know what we can hear
and if they disagree with you they can
take you off if they don't like the
competition they can take you away
that's the problem so what do you see as
the answer is this we go in and we have
regulators look at the algorithm this is
you know i always have this running joke
that you're going to have some middle
management bureaucrat going to google
like let me see the algorithm
as if or are we breaking them up i mean
where does competition fit in like
what's the
this is the way up here the first
approach we should take is
everybody should realize if something's
on the internet that's free
you're the product yeah okay so if
you're the product we should think of
ourselves as private property right
so if i'm the product and or private
property
what goes on your site if you're
monetizing it i get a piece of it
and i get to know what you're doing with
my information right it's not like this
form
that attorney has to read everyone just
clicks yes or no
let's set a foundation of what the
priorities of these forms should be so
they're clear spoken that people know
what they're getting i get
i get if you're monetizing i get a piece
of it if i want to get off your site
i get my data back if i want to move my
data i can move my data
i think that's a fairness that everybody
starts with the other thing that has to
happen here is though
we've got to make sure there's a level
playing field where there's competition
and i don't think big government
creating utility is there competition
for pg e
no they just raise our rates and they
give us brownouts
and we pay 40 higher anybody else i want
somebody to come in and disrupt
i want the next one right we had
microsoft before we had google
and the other challenge is if somebody
wants to go to court it takes too long
right so i understand at the beginning
why we gave you section 230
right you wanted the platform to begin
i will keep 230 and only this
perspective
if you let people say on the platform
whatever they want because it's
liability protection
for you to allow the people to do that
but is it too late i mean i've had this
conversation with other congress people
and
plenty of pundits and everything else
like it's like why didn't anything
happen then
when when they dragged zuckerberg in
front of congress
section 230 still there so if you remove
section 230
now now the platform has a question to
make
if i want to regulate what's on there
right a person has a right to go to
court
if we go to court one time do a big
class action i'll guarantee you they'll
change their behavior
structure dictates behavior right now
this isn't that isn't that what trump is
now announcing he's doing just in the
last couple days so he's going to do a
class for one moment regardless of how
anyone feels about trump
yeah he had the most
people on facebook probably the most
followers on twitter
he was the president of the united
states our very first amendment is
freedom of speech
and they took them off and the place i
heard the most complaints from
was merkel in germany i mean think about
it
yeah 32 years ago a million college kids
went to tenement square
for the idea of freedom of speech the
three million people out of eight
million in hong kong that would go out
in the rain
crave freedom of speech and we had just
allowed that to be denied
to an american and then once they did it
to him they did it to everybody else
that they disagreed with why have we
come so far that
you and i can't could sit down you could
have a total different philosophy
we could debate but we don't have to
dislike each other
when we take away the debate we're
taking away a foundation of who we
are i mean i should not be afraid that
someone has a different belief and i and
debate the idea
it either makes my ideas stronger makes
me believe more i mean
i'm a republican but my family are all
democrats i chose to be in this party so
when someone wants to challenge me on my
conservative belief
i wasn't born here i chose to come here
i think i'm going to have a stronger
belief
i rejected what somebody said at home
and was seeking out something else wait
let's stick with that for a moment
because i think you know a little bit
about my story
and i was i was a big lefty so i'm
curious i didn't know that about you so
you come from a family of democrats what
what
i was working for my family what was
your moment
so i'm older than we'll get back i'm 56
yeah
reagan was the first president i could
vote for it was it was in his second
term
but when i was in elementary school i
watched junior high
jimmy carter go on tv
put a sweater on tell me to turn the
heater down and told me the best days
of america were behind us he accept
mediocracy
then watch this other guy go to a podium
and says no pastels
fly the bold colors and go to that shiny
city on the hill
i knew what he meant right that
america is exceptional right if you ever
if you come to my office i want you to
come to d.c
so i have this portrait of reagan behind
me it's in color right
and i have this other portrait that's
very big and it's
lincoln and it's in black and white the
greatest challenge
ever to our constitution was the civil
war
and at night if you sat back and what's
happening and you asked these two people
to give us advice today lincoln would
say
believe in exceptionalism of america and
this is what makes me mad coming off the
4th of july
why wouldn't we celebrate the progress
we're not perfect but as we strive for
our perfect union lincoln said
conceived in liberty and dedicated the
proposition that we're
all equal he goes on to say but if we
fail government of the people by the
people for the people
shall not perish from earth we weren't
the world power but he understood
the strength of what a democracy and
republican were right
there is no other nation in the world
conceived in liberty
and dedicated they're all equal maybe
israel but no other one
right lincoln would also tell us this
right
as an elected official don't be afraid
of making a tough decision
right the whole debate of slavery didn't
start in 1850
it was the creation of our country but
they thought it was too
too divided too divisional right that it
would divide us divide the colonies so
they said to put it aside in doing so
hundreds of thousands of their children
died we don't have a decision like that
today
but our debt our challenge with china
right
are we too afraid as elected official to
make a decision that we can lose upon
but what happens is you narrow it you're
eventually going to make decisions but
you have fewer options
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell